- But tomorrow is Valentine's day.
- Yes!
- Do you celebrate
Valentine's day, or are you kind of anti?
- Well, lets not forget
about Galentine's Day.
- Let's not.
(people cheering)
- So Galentine's Day, for
those of you that don't know,
is the writers of Parks and Rec created
this kind of fake holiday
where Leslie Knope,
the character I played on the show,
would go out with her gals,
her friends and celebrate,
so I celebrate Galentine's
Day all the time,
and in fact I'm spending Galentine's Day
with Rashida Jones and Aubrey
Plaza and Kathryn Hahn,
we're having dinner tonight.
- Oh, that's awesome.
(people cheering)
(clapping)
- I celebrated Galentine's
Day until I was like 30.
(laughing)
I mean for real, so I'm very aware.
- And if you are gay then
every Valentine's day
is Galentine's Day.
(people cheering)
- Exactly, lucky.
Woman are a good time.
- [Amy] For sure.
- Gay or not, it's a fun time.
- It's a fun time.
I think it's fun to make
up your own holidays.
- Yes.
- Right?
- And we should, yeah.
And I just think you need
to start making cards.
Then you can profit
off of this great idea.
(laughing)
- You're so right.
- Just saying.
- There's a lot of money
I'm leaving on the table.
- You are, you're just giving it away.
(laughing)
But did you ever have to do,
I remember in school I always,
we had to do the Valentine's Day things,
either you had to do carnations, or--
- We did carnations.
- We did carnations too.
- We had to write,
who you wanted to give a carnation to
and then a kid would
show up at your classroom
with a box of carnations,
and kind of call out everyone's name,
it was just so horrible right?
- Which is because, I never got one.
Did you?
Were you that kid?
I wasn't at all there were so many of us,
there literally be like
five people that got them.
And it would be like, well
I guess it wasn't my turn,
like it was like--
- And all those people, like yeah,
all those people who got
them kind of peaked to early
and it's been a tough
go for them ever since.
(audience laughing)
- You peaked in high school.
- I want to peak in high school.
- But it also is, and
it's not an ah thing to,
cause then you'd find out
its just a girlfriend,
that send it to her girlfriend
so she didn't feel lame.
- [Both] Yeah.
- And that doesn't count, cheater.
- Yeah, I feel like nowadays people,
you know like schools don't
really pressure you as much
as they did when I was
growing up in the 80's,
it was a lot of like, who
are you going to marry?
Who's your boyfriend?
And you're like, I'm in third grade.
(people laughing)
- That's in the South,
they do that all the time.
Its like every time at a holiday,
its like who's your boyfriend,
I'm like, why can't I just be me?
Like I didn't bring anyone
because I'm in second grade,
but yeah they push you in
the South for some reason.
- They do it in Boston to.
- Speaking of your show,
I love Boston, I really.
- You do?
- I, that's not even a
part of our conversation,
but it's one of my
favorite places to tour,
because y'all are like Texans with sports.
- Yes, yes.
- Y'all are so hardcore,
it is awesome.
I was there when y'all broke
the 80 whatever year streak,
or whatever, I was at
that game, I got to sing,
and I was like, literally y'all are crazy.
- Wait I remember this because
I was watching that game.
- Steven Tyler was there to
it was one of the, whatever,
the world series but it was in that thing
that y'all ended up breaking the streak
and y'all, you would have
thought, we landed on Mars.
- [Amy] Yeah.
- Like where we made it!
- We are hardcore about our sports.
- Sports.